ويضم الينا من اكياس عماد ابو الرب رئيس
المركز الاوكره للتواصل والحوار اهلا
وسهلا بك بدايه الجيش الاوكرانيه يقول او
يؤكد ان محمود هي النقطه الاكثر سخونه على
الجبهه اليوم حيث يدور قتال عنيف لماذا
بخمول تحديدا وما الفائده الاستراتيجيه
والعسكريه من هذه المنطقه
يعني
جيوس سياسيه واستراتيجيه عسكريه كميدان
روسيا لم تحقق خلال شهور الماضيه اي اهداف
تذكر فبالتالي هي معنيه باي شكل ان تن تن
تنجز اي شيء وبالتالي كل هذه الحشود
الدار
واستطاعت حقيقه ان تتقدم في اجزاء منها
وهذا ما اكده ايضا
القياده العسكريه الاخرانيه ان المدينه
اييه تحت السيطره الاوكرانيات التي تدافع
عنها ولكنها بدات تستخدم فيها اسلوب
تكتيكي وهو الانسحاب مع الهجوم المضاد
للقوات المتواجده على بعض اجزاء سوليدار
السلطات الاوكرانيه يتحدث عن قيام مجموعه
فاجنر بهجوم او بهجوم عنيف على بلده
سوليدر هل هناك رصد لي عناصر خارجيه
وعناصر من المرتزقه داخل هذه المجموعات
وغيرها هل هناك تواجد اكبر لمجموعات في
هذه المرحله من الصراع
بالتاكيد هناك عده الاف من الباكمر من
الان لم يعني يتبين منهم لكن باعتقادي مع
وقوع البعض ان استطاعت القوات الاوكرانيه
ان تاثر او البعض القتلى سيكون التعرق
الاساسي ان اغلبيه هؤلاء ايضا قوات خاصه
من الشيشان التي يعلن عنها الرئيس
الشيشاني لكن الواضح ان الجبهه ستكون
شديده لا لن تسقط مدينه باخبط بهذه
السهوله ان كان هناك مؤشر
ان الساعات القديمه القادمه الساعه تحسم
على الاقل منطقه سوليدار للدرجه الاولى
ضربات تتكثف في الشرق الان
في العاصمه
وغرب اوكرانيا كله امن حتى لا يوجد صافرات
انذار في الفتره الاخيره قبل اربعه ايام
الى اليوم لم يسمع اي صوت
الانذار لكن للاسف المنطقه الشرقيه
الجنوبيه هناك قصف دائم وسؤالكم جاء في
مكانه لان البعض الان يركز فقط
ينسى ان مدينه خارطه
همم يتم همم تعرض يوميا لقصف وبعضها للاسف
استهدف اسواق ومباني سكنيه ومركز طبي وكان
خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه قرابه الثلاثه
واكثر من 20 جريح في هذه المدن
كتنسيق غربي الان يتكثف ايضا لي همم تزويد
همم اوكرانيا بالاسلحه بريطانيا تدرس
بالدبابات لاول مره هناك ايضا اجتماع في
حلف الناتو بحسب الكريم لان هذه الاسلحه
الجديده ستععمق معاناه الشعب الاوكراني
ولن تؤثر على نتيجه الصراع ميدانيا هل هذا
الى اي ماذا يمكن ان نتخذ او ناخذ هذه
العبارات على محمل الجهد هل بالفعل هذه
الاسلحه لن تغير كثيرا على ارض الواقع
بالنسبه للنظر الاوكرانيه على العكس هي
تعتبر ان هذه الاسلحه هي التي ستخفف
معاناه الشعب الاوكراني لماذا لان انا على
الافق السياسي للاسف
كبير بين الجانبين نجد اسرار روسي على
اقتحام المدن الاوكرانيه والسيطره عليها
دون ااا الاخذ بعين الاعتبار الضحايا التي
تذهب من الارواح البشريه او من البناء
التحتيه المدنيه فبالتالي مع كل هذا
الاصرار باعتقاد الاجتماع اليوم والخطاب
والبيان المشتركه للناس والاتحاد الاوروبي
يؤكد على ان الناتو ماضي في مساعدته
واوكرانيا ستستفيد من هذه المساعدات لانها
تقنيه وفنيا استطاعت ان تتقن اا اداره
واستخدام هذه التقنيات العسكريه الجديده
رئيس المركز الاوكرانيه للتواصل شكرا
جزيلا لكم